Nathan, you've
missed so much.
The town's revamp,
my 18th birthday.
I did send
you that Cameo
from Olivia
Rodrigo's horse.
That horse did not
phone it in.
I love an animal who
knows her angles.
Reagan, I really
need your help.
Nathan, you had a little
bit of a rough patch,
but adversity
makes us stronger.
No Reags,
is this sweater
too sexy?
For what?
What about vest?
Welcome to the new
Minishonka
Cultural Center.
This is Nelson,
my co-curator.
You're touching those
with bare hands?
Would you want to be
touched with
with hands
covered in gloves?
You don't know
what I'm into, man.
Nice to see
you, Ms. Fish.
I listened to that
podcast about you.
I have Josh's info if
you want to dox him.
Well I find
that troubling.
Hey, Terry.
Regan's in a Rez fight.
Oh, tell her she hits
the ground it's over.
Listen, Matriarch
to Matriarch.
That is bonker donkers.